all right if you like most Americans you
grew up with a special sense of
reverence for judges watching films or
reading books you know regular folks
have seen countless portrayal of judges
as consummate professionals who set
their own personal opinions aside and
objectively weigh the merits of each
case since there has been no previous
violation of this statute there is no
precedent to guide the bench passing
sentence the witness will address this
court as judge or your honor I'm quite
certain I've earned it since the United
States government declares this man to
be Santa Claus this Court will not
dispute it case dismissed
I still get goosebumps every time I see
that well but of course then there's a
real world where certain judges act more
like political pundits than impartial
arbiters case in point
yesterday's sentencing hearing a former
Trump national security advisor Michael
Flynn judge Emmett Sullivan most
recently a clinton appointee used his
moment in the spotlight to castigate
Flynn with incendiary charges that
weren't even brought by the special
counsel at one point he told the
decorated lieutenant general arguably
you sold your country out well then he
cited Flynn's failure to register as a
foreign agent and the judge actually
used the word treason but with clever
phrasing he told the court I wasn't
suggesting that he was committing
treason I was just curious if he could
have been charged
lots of conspiracy theories out there
since when do judges start invoking
conspiracy theories as grounds for
imposing additional jail time or any
jail time in a defendant the Special
Counsel
actually remember recommended no jail
time nevertheless judge Sullivan warned
Flynn that even if he cooperated further
with the special counsel he could still
serve time this has to be one of the
most dramatic he
that I have ever witnessed and I've been
here in Washington nearly 20 years it
only got worse by the way naturally
liberal pundits were quick to cheer
their honorable comrade and arms
activism but I will tell you this that
today
a judge in Washington DC stood up for
our country he spanked everybody in
Washington the judge can exhibit
whatever type of temperament the judge
would like to is it to exhibit in the
judges courses none of them understood
the basic moral outrage that Judge
Sullivan was going to bring to the
proceedings I think that today was a
really good day for the justice system
and that this judge really did his job
totally well sure they loved the judges
theatrics because he's part of the
resistance and today he might have
earned himself a full-time CNN
contributors contract given the latest
ruling in a pre-christmas permanent
injunction judge Sullivan and believe it
or not I read all 170 Dias pages this
afternoon ruled that Trump's tightening
guidelines for granting asylum is
illegal remember back when is ekend june
when jeff sessions announced these new
asylum rules asylum is available for
those who leave their home country
because of persecution or fear on
account of race religion nationality or
membership in a particular social group
or political opinion asylum was never
meant to alleviate all problems even all
serious problems that people face every
day all over the world common sense
interpretation no well the move was
needed because asylum seekers were
abusing the system aided by a lot of
leftist NGOs migrants began parroting
lines about gang violence and domestic
violence to establish this expanded
credible fear category because they
don't want to return to their homeland
which judge Sullivan's opinion today
it's back to business as usual pre Trump
the way it used to be the judge not only
by the way demands that the
administration revert
to the old rules of asylum entry but
further he instructed that the
government returned to the United States
the plaintiffs who were unlawfully
deported and to provide them with new
credible fear determinations consistent
with the immigration laws would you like
a mint on your pillow - in other words
all those deported have to be brought
back for new asylum hearings now I guess
they can stay at Sullivan's house as
they await trial who knows but from his
activist judicial high-horse sullivan
apparently isn't bothered by the growing
backlog of 800,000 now immigration court
cases 30% of those involve asylum
requests that's more than triple the
number from 2009 now we've been talking
about the scourge of unelected judges
substituting their own policy
preferences for those of the American
people's representatives since this show
started back in October of last year
the president ultimately won remember on
its travel ban at the Supreme Court but
for every issue from transgender people
serving in the military to climate
change to the 2020 census to the
Keystone pipeline these activist judges
have waged an assault on Trump's agenda
and they've exceeded their
constitutional authority in almost every
instance we're reminded of how important
it is that Trump gets his judicial
nominees confirmed as quickly as
possible Mitch McConnell has done a
pretty good job but we need this done
faster more expeditiously and like
yesterday and and if this means staying
in session
for an extra few days every month or
even maybe into the Christmas holiday
well guess what the country depends on
it the Constitution depends on it and
shame on Congress for not doing its job
in the first place and passing urgently
needed Asylum reform at any point in the
last two years they had the house in the
Senate they should have addressed this
issue they should have done a lot on
immigration including passed that
funding for the wall they didn't shame
on them shame on these judicial
activists and that's the angle